just we get started on this one I do
want to say that there are gonna be some
Vietnamese pronunciations I am NOT
Vietnamese I do not speak Vietnamese but
I do try my best let's get into it
Ho Chi Minh
father of independent Viet Nam was a man
of contrasts standing at just 4 feet 11
inches and weighing less than a hundred
pounds he appeared to pose no threat to
anyone yet through the force of his
personality and the steely determination
of his will he defeated two of the
world's mightiest nations he betrayed
himself as a simple man of the people
yet he ruled over a repressive regime
that committed terrible atrocities
while many viewed him as the bringer of
light to a repressed people to others he
was simply a communist spy planted by
the Soviets in today's by graphics we
discover the truth about the real Ho Chi
Minh
[Music]
Ho Chi Minh was born on May the 1989 tea
in the village of Huang true in what was
French Indochina he was given the birth
name yuanchen cool from the age of five
he lived in the village of LAN Xang in
the near and province this was the
hometown of his father knew and sing
sach sach was a man of learning being a
Confucian scholar and a teacher Chun was
the third child and the second son to
sach and his wife another child would
follow but this son died in infancy by
the end of the 19th century French
Indochina was France's most prosperous
colony with huge profits being made from
rubber and rice exports the jewel in the
crown was the area known today as
Vietnam the native people there mostly
worked on the large French owned rubber
plantations they were pressed on to work
gangster toil for very long hours with
very little reward any rebellions were
violently stamped out by the French
authorities the new and family were of
the upper class of Vietnamese society
cum was instructed by his father until
around the age of seven years when
formal instruction began under a scholar
by the name of Volk dokdo the boy was a
quick study mastering the art of Chinese
calligraphy instruction in Confucianism
lay at the core of his studies and he
rapidly came to embrace its tenets
outside of the classroom Kung displayed
an inquisitive mind and an adventurous
spirit his passions they were kite
flying and fishing when he was 10 years
old in accordance with Confucian
tradition his father gave him a new name
new at that thang which means new in' he
accomplished when he was 11 Dan's family
were struck with tragedy while his
father was away on business his mother
gave birth to a fourth child however she
did not survive the delivery son was
devastated but he had no time to mourn
he no siblings had the responsibility of
looking after a newborn infant until
their father returned by this time sach
had become a Mandarin or a local
official the job kept him away from home
for long periods at a time as a widower
he now had to rely on his family and
friends to help look after his children
in his preteens than began attending a
French boarding school in the city of
way along with his older brother Zach
was of the view that for his boys to
succeed in making their mark on the
worlds they would need to have the
benefit of a French education however
sach was no longer a supporter of the
French regime just by being an official
of the indo-chinese government he was an
outspoken critic of the manner in which
the local authorities had so willingly
ceded all power
and control to the French this criticism
it did not go unnoticed eventually he
would be dismissed from his position
after a man died who sac ordered be
given 102 lashes as punishment for a
minor wrongdoing following his dismissal
Sackler came greatly embittered against
the French indo-chinese bureaucracy
unable to find work he spent the rest of
his life traveling from village to
village in search of a way to make a
living dan saw very little of his father
from then on he too became angry with
the system and especially the French
rulers who treated the local people so
badly by 1908 Fant had been studying at
the national academy in quei for four
years one day he saw a large group of
peasants marching past the school these
people were protesting corruption in the
government and high taxation it has long
been related that Dan joins the protest
and that he translated the demands of
the people into French in order for the
colonial rulers to understand what their
grievances were as a result the story
goes that he was dismissed from the
school however a recently discovered
French document shows that he was
admitted to the prestigious College Quoc
hoc in a way in August of 1908 an
expulsion would have made him ineligible
for entry in his later life however he
pointed to that protest in early 1908 as
the point when his revolutionary fervor
emerged upon completion of his studies
in 1911 van took a position as a teacher
at the duck fan school then Fant yet on
the eastern coast he stayed there for
some six months he then moved to Saigon
the bustling metropolis in the
southwestern part of the country
[Music]
his four years of study had allowed that
to become fluent in the French language
it had also given the good understanding
of French culture and its history he was
aware of the principles of liberty
equality and fraternity that had
underpinned the French Revolution he
knew that those principles were not
being adopted in French Indochina but he
was very curious to see how they were
being put into action in France itself
in June of 1931 that got his chance to
satisfy his urge to explore France he
managed to get a position as a kitchen
helper on a French steamship a one month
journey brought the ship into Marseille
on July the fifth on arrival in France
then applied for entrance into a school
that trained officials to serve in the
colonies the application though there
was denied having arrived in France he
still needed the means to support
himself he decided that his best bet was
to continue working as a kitchen hands
on ships where he knew that he was able
to secure work as a result of this he
spent the next six years travelling the
world on various steam ships this gave
him the opportunity to visit many
colonial countries and compare the life
and conditions to what he knew back in
French Indochina Vance travels took him
to Africa South America into the United
States on a 1912 trip he jumped ship at
Boston Harbor and made his way to New
York he claims to have lived and worked
in Boston and New York for some time
though the only evidence of his being in
the u.s. at that time is a letter he
wrote home that has eight New York
postmark on it while in the US then was
surprised to learn that immigrants to
America had legal rights that the French
in Indochina would not have even given
to the native people their most
importantly that the right to vote
something which greatly impressed him
just prior to the outbreak of World War
one Dan sailed for England he worked as
a pastry chef in the Carlton Hotel in
Westminster during his London years he
began to associate with people of
different nationalities and they all had
one thing in common they came from
either British or French colonies and
were experiencing oppression and
domination by the colonial masters over
the course of many late-night
discussions then came to dedicate
himself to the liberation of his
homeland
[Music]
by 1917 Phan had become an accomplished
pastry chef and had a solid career path
laid out before him however he decided
to forego that opportunity he moved to
Paris in order to learn the craft of the
revolutionary him he moved into the
Parisian Vietnamese Quarter which was
quite large during his first 12 months
in the French capital he immersed
himself in the culture and the glamour
of the city to support himself he worked
as a cook and a photo retoucher but his
primary purpose was to organize expat
Vietnamese into a strong enough force to
affect some real change back in
Indochina valent was surprised that
quite a number of Frenchmen were
sympathetic to the plight of the
Vietnamese people they encouraged him to
publish his ideas about what needed to
be done and he did just that producing
an anti-colonial newspaper targeted
towards the expat of the enemy's
population or throughout France copies
they even made their way back to
Indochina he wrote about the terrible
conditions for the native people not
just in France but in every colony biet
French or British at this stage his
writings they didn't call for a
revolution that simply demanded fairer
treatment and equal rights the risings
of thon they made their way to the
colonial governments in Indochina he was
immediately condemned as a revolutionary
and condemned to death if he ever
returned to his homeland meanwhile the
native people of French Indochina they
hailed him as a hero
vang was in Paris at the time of the
Treaty of a science became involved with
a group of Vietnamese nationalists who
tried to take their message to the
International Congress the statesmen
were basing their restructuring of
post-war Europe on the principles of
self-determination and democracy the
Vietnamese nationalists they wanted them
to apply those very principles to
Vietnam however they were largely
ignored by the International Congress
[Music]
with the establishment of Soviet Russia
the worldwide socialist movement was
suddenly split between two ideologies
social democracy and capitalism and
livin in Paris made the fateful decision
to firmly throw in with communists in
1920 he became one of the founding
members of the French Communist Party
then began to write pro-communist
articles for the anti-colonial newspaper
la pariah then three years later he made
a trip to Russia there he met with
Marxist leaders who encouraged him to
view the struggle for Vietnamese
independence as a part of the
International communist struggle to
overthrow capitalism
he became the member of the Comintern
the organization set up by the Soviets
to take communism to the world Phan was
convinced that the example set by the
Russian Communist revolution provided
the model for overthrow in French
Indochina in June of 1924 the Soviet
government sent them to Canton China to
begin laying the groundwork for the
communist takeover of Asia from this
point on in his life fan would operate
as an underground figure he traveled
under aliases and lived in Mountain
hideaways as he worked clandestinely to
organize communist resistance movements
in 1927 the Chinese authorities clamped
down on the Communists than was nearly
arrested narrowly making his escape into
Siam in Siam Phan took on the persona of
a Buddhist monk this allowed him to
travel freely in the north of the
country there were a large Vietnamese
population it was there that he headed
preaching his communist messages he
wandered from village to village
throughout the majority of the 1930s
then disappeared from the record books
there were rumors of him being in
various places such as with Mao seat
song and the Chinese Highlands or in
Soviet Russia with Stalin there were
even some reports that he was dead
[Music]
his later re-emergence on the world
stage after the outbreak of the Second
World War proved that the last rumor was
wrong for the past 15 years he had been
biding his time as he waited for the
opportune moment to lead his people in
rebellion against France when France
felt like a house of cards to the German
assault in just six weeks in mid 1940 he
felt that the time had finally come a
new French government that cooperated
with the occupying Nazis was set up in
Vichy France this Vichy government also
took control of French Indochina but
under the Dominion of the Japanese who
are also one of the Axis powers along
with Germany and Italy at the beginning
of 1941 Phan re-entered Indochina for
the first time in 30 years he entered
the northern jungle he had great plans
for an overthrow of the French but
trailers allows he carried no weapons
with him he had few followers and little
money he immediately set about
recruiting support among the mountain
communities his revolutionary group was
called Viet Minh da clap Minh which was
soon shortened to Viet Minh the goal of
this new group was to create a
broad-based nationalist movement for the
reclaiming of Vietnamese independence
and to gain the support of other nations
especially the Chinese the Viet Minh
also vowed to oust the Japanese fascists
along with their french accomplices it
was at this time that an adopted the
name by which he would become famous
around the world Ho Chi Minh which means
bringer of light the name change was a
calculated move to present himself as a
wise sage in the Confucian tradition how
lived the life of a peasant in order to
win the people to his course he spoke in
simple language and rejected all
materialism in pursuit of the cause of
nationalism he also cultivated the image
of a lifelong salaburu simply didn't
have the time for a wife in 1942 he went
to China in order to recruit extra
manpower however he was arrested for
being a communist and spent 14 months in
a Chinese prison he finally convinced
his captors to release him so that he
could spy for them against the Japanese
in Indochina he walked all the way back
to his mountain base his followers had
given him up for dead but they
enthusiastically welcomed him back as
their leader there were other
revolutionary groups at the time but
only the Viet Minh managed to establish
a number of clandestine cells around the
country
small-scale guerrilla activities against
the Japanese they continued throughout
the duration of the war
then the Japanese they did something
unexpected on March the 9th 1945 fearing
an Allied invasion they overthrew the
French established government and
declared an end to the French colony of
Indochina the former nations of Lao and
Cambodia were freed from the colonial
yoke to once again be independent
kingdoms the Vietnamese provinces of
Annam and Tonkin were given to the
rulership of Bao Dai still this was not
genuine independence the Viet Minh bided
their time they knew that the Japanese
would eventually be defeated and after
leave their land
at that time they would step into the
vacuum with the dropping of two atomic
bombs on Hiroshima and Nagasaki in
August of 1945 the game it was up for
the Japanese they swiftly left Indochina
creating the vacuum that ho chi minh had
predicted ho promptly declared Vietnam
to be independent and set up a
government which was based at Hanoi the
president have been put in place by the
Japanese Bao Dai could see the will of
the people and quickly abdicated its
position the French either had
absolutely no intentions of giving up
their hold on the colony as far as they
were concerned now that the war was over
and the Axis powers had been defeated
things would revert to how they were in
the 1930s but they were to find a
greatly strengthened Viet Minh the
American Office of Strategic Services
OSS had seen the Viet Minh as a useful
Ally in defeating the Japanese and so
had given support to Ho Chi Minh's
guerrilla forces the new government set
about bringing relief to the masses who
had suffered under the Japanese rule and
were now largely at the point of
starvation ho put together a declaration
of independence which he modeled after
the American version of 1776 this was
done in an attempt to win American
support for that part the Americans
though they were wary dead of natural
inclination to want to assist native
peoples to overthrow their colonial
overlords just as they had done nearly
two hundred years before but they also
wanted to maintain as good a
relationship as possible with the French
the two countries had a long history
dating back to the very founding of the
United States the French had backed them
against the common enemy Great Britain
supplying millions of dollars as well as
ships and Men it was decided by the
Allies that the British would occupy the
area of the south of the country or the
16th parallel in order to accept the
surrender of the Japanese in Vietnam the
area north of the 16th parallel would be
occupied by the Tri
is China agreed to allow the Viet Minh
under ho to remain in power
the British though they saw it
differently they felt obligated to help
the French restore their pre-war
position in October of 1945 French
forces aided by the British landed in
southern Vietnam and began to quash any
and all Viet Minh resistance that they
encountered the French status quo was
established in Saigon and other key
centers
however the countryside it was rife with
Viet Minh guerrilla fighters then under
pressure from the Allied powers the
Chinese relented and allowed the French
to take power north of the French
parallel also the Viet Minh governments
of the Ho Chi Minh was forced to
compromise the French proposed a form of
vietnamese self-governance
inside of a french ruled Indochina
Federation Ho and an entourage they flew
to France to negotiate a peace deal but
there was to be no deal the French were
only willing to concede limited
self-rule which was a far cry from what
the Viet Minh were demanding the talks
broke down and Howe returned to Vietnam
without a solution in November of 1946
the rising tensions between the Viet
Minh and the French they sparked into
open warfare the French began an air
bombardment of the coastal city of
Haiphong this led to an evacuation of
the port by the Vietnamese then in
December the Viet Minh launched a
full-scale attack on the French position
in Hanoi when this failed to find
success the native forces withdrew to
the mountains in order to undertake a
campaign of full-scale guerrilla war
that over the next eight years the Viet
Minh under whose skillful leadership
ground down the will of the French
military by 1954 the French were
desperate to end the war they decided to
launch a surprise attack on the Viet
Minh as a place called en bien phu the
french thought they were luring hos
guerillas into a trap but their plan
backfired terribly and dn bien phu ended
up as a disaster for the me it was two
months of fighting and at least 15,000
french soldiers were killed the final
vietnamese assault was launched on may
the 1st for several days the battle
raged on until the french they were
finally subjugated more than 10,000
prisoners were taken this it was the
final straw for the french and they
admitted defeat
[Music]
in early 1954 the leaders of the United
States Britain France and the Soviet
Union agreed to convene an international
convention in Geneva in order to work
out peace settlements regarding the two
major Asian conflicts Korea and
Indochina the conference began in April
the first issue was Korea discussions
that know where and in the end the terms
of the ceasefire of the previous year
they continued to rule the situation
then the focus is switched to Indochina
after heated discussions an agreement
was finally ironed out between the
French and the it men Cambodia and Laos
where to be granted their independence
without the intervention or threat of
communist takeover in Vietnam itself all
Viet Minh forces were to regroup north
of the 17th parallel the French would
withdraw to the south of this arbitrary
line and so the country it was divided
into north and south but only
temporarily the Geneva Accord stipulated
that elections were to be held in two
years in order to unify Vietnam under a
single democratic government a communist
government under Ho Chi Minh was now
officially established north of the 17th
parallel south of then line the Republic
of Vietnam was installed with node
Indian as his first president for 300
days after the signing of the Geneva
Accords the borders were open allowing
for people to move between north and
south approximately 1 million people
took advantage of this opportunity to
escape communism and move south ho now
concentrated on building the communist
state of North Vietnam the lands reform
program was started based on the model
created by Mao in China many landowners
they were executed and corruption was
widespread
in the south the us-backed governments
of president no Jing dim was
anti-communist and more corrupt than it
was in the north diem was unpopular with
the people in the south he along with
his American backers did not allow the
Geneva Accord stipulated unifying
elections to take place if they had Ho
Chi Minh would have undoubtedly won by
the end of the 1950s and EDM sentiment
in the South had given rise to a civil
war the southern guerrillas they were
called the Viet Cong Ho said Viet Minh
fighters in to support them in return
the US sent advisers in to help the
governmental forces of diem the real
goal of the US however was to stop the
spread of communism
[Music]
by the mid-1960s the Vietnam War was
raging with thousands of Americans
fighting against the Viet Minh Ho Chi
Minh was now a frail old man of 76 years
it's unlikely that he was involved any
longer in any day-to-day military
operations however he was as he had
always been the major source of
inspiration for the Vietnamese people to
fight and win their independence no
matter the cost
ho Chi Minh died on September the 2nd
1969 it would be six more years until
the Americans would be defeated and
Vietnamese independence finally achieved
but the Vietnamese people they owed that
independence to the tenacity the vision
and the determination of that visionary
leader Ho Chi Minh so I really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do give us a thumbs up below and
don't forget to subscribe we've got
brand new videos just like this most
days of the week and hit that Bell
notification you actually find out about
them in your feed which is always nice
also if you're looking for more from me
why not check out another channel I do
called highlight history which is linked
to below and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]